-I'm so happy you're here.
Welcome back.
-It's so good to be here again.
Hi, everyone.
-How's it feel, the audience?
-The last time,
we did this online.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's so good.
Hi, everyone.
Real people. I love real people.
I love real people.
-Yeah, exactly.
Thank you for being here.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-And you.
-I know, and you, bud.
I miss you.
We have to talk
about so many things.
I want to talk about your song
with Snoop Dogg.
But before we get into that,
you were just
at an Oscars luncheon
out in -- Where was it?
-It was
for The Hollywood Reporter
and I saw Questlove there.
-Yeah.
-That's why he's not here.
But hi, guys.
-Here's your buddy.
You and Questlove backstage.
-Yeah.
[ Audience awws ]
I know. I'm so excited for him
because he got nominated
and, yeah.
-His documentary's fantastic.
-So he should be.
-It's "Summer of Soul."
It's awesome.
But you guys go back a long way.
-Well, I mean, we've been
doing Halloween
for many, many, many years
because he always brings
the music for my party.
So this year
we're definitely back on
because things are getting
better and better and better,
I feel like, so I'm excited
that we can actually do
the party again, yeah.
-You always go for it.
It's fantastic.
-I always do.
You just got back
from Germany, right?
-Well, I'm filming a show also
in Germany.
I do "Germany's Next Topmodel"
and that's how I did that song
with Snoop Dogg,
because they asked me,
why don't I sing the theme song
for this new season
and I was like, "Hey,
you don't have to ask me twice
[ Laughter ]
to sing something
for you guys."
So I was like, "Yes, I would
love to, but maybe not alone.
Maybe I'll do it with someone
who actually sings.
Or raps, perhaps."
So then, you know, I literally
asked one of my favorites,
which is Snoop Dogg.
Literally called him up
and he said,
"Let's make it happen."
I'm like, "Okay,
how do we make it happen?"
He said,
"Well, come to Inglewood,"
and then we worked
on the song together, yeah.
-I mean, were you nervous at all
that you're --
-Of course!
-Yeah.
And did you go in knowing
kind of what you're singing,
or no?
-So, my husband, he is part
of a band called Tokio Hotel
-Yeah, awesome.
-and he also is doing
a DJ project and that is,
you know,
something that he has
put together.
So he wrote the song
and then I went to Inglewood
to see Snoop Dogg
so he rapped over it.
But then I was always
kind of thinking,
"So what am I going to do?"
And then in the shower,
I thought it would be
kind of cool to sing the song
"Baby Jane" by Rod Stewart
-Yeah, I know that song.
-and so I did.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but now here's
where it gets tricky,
because now you have to ask --
-Because I have so many ideas
and then I call everyone
and like see
to kind of put it all together.
-Yeah, but then you have
to find Rod Stewart
and get his permission.
-And can I just
tell you something?
That was the hardest thing
to do.
They should do a movie
about finding Rod Stewart.
[ Laughter ]
Where is he hiding?
Where's Rod Stewart?
Because it was very easy
to find Snoop Dogg, you know.
[ Laughter ]
I just had a few calls and then
I had Snoop Dogg on the line.
But Rod Stewart, boy,
he's hard to find.
[ Laughter ]
So, I asked everyone.
One day I'm sitting
at the hairdresser,
getting my highlights done
because I'm not a real blond.
[ Laughter ]
And then I asked her
if she would possibly know
Rod Stewart
because I called, you know,
everyone I know.
-He's got great hair.
[ Laughter ]
-It's like, "No, no, no."
And she said, "Well, I know
his daughter Kimberly" --
-She would know
where Rod Stewart is.
-So then I emailed her.
[ Laughter ]
She would know.
So, sure enough, she emailed him
or forwarded my email on to him.
And then I don't hear anything
and so I'm like,
"Wow, he hates it," you know?
-So he hates the song.
-So I thought he hated the song.
Everything was for nothing.
-You can't do the song.
-I did all this for nothing.
So, after maybe like one or two
months, someone said to me,
"Well, have you checked
your spam mail?
He probably is
in the spam mail."
I'm like,
"No, you probably hates it."
I look in the spam mail.
He's in the spam mail.
[ Laughter ]
For two months, I've been
sitting around waiting,
thinking he hates it.
Meanwhile, he was like,
"I love it. Go for it."
-Rod the Mod, Rob the Bod.
-Yes!
-We love you, Rod Stewart!
-Yes, we do!
-He's a good man!
-Yes! So then, that's how
I got to sing "Baby Jane."
I mean, I'm still
mind-blown about it.
-I want to show everyone
a little bit of the video,
if you don't mind.
-Oh, yeah, please do.
This is you with Snoop Dogg
in the music video
for "Chai Tea" with Heidi.
-♪ Ready, set,
stand where the light be ♪
♪ You know it's lit when it's
Snoop Dogg and Heidi ♪
♪ The walk mean,
fierce, feisty girl ♪
♪ You're hot and you're sweet
like chai tea ♪
♪ You say I'm always high ♪
♪ We keep that on the low ♪
♪ Flossy, it's a fun day
on the runway ♪
♪ You can let it go ♪
-♪ When I give my heart again ♪
♪ I know ♪
♪ It's gonna last forever ♪
♪ No one tell me where
or when ♪
♪ I know ♪
♪ It's gonna last forever ♪
-I mean, come on!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hello.
You have a song with Snoop Dogg.
-I know.
-It's amazing!
-Like literally, you know,
and I keep saying this --
a lot of people
have like a bucket list
of things that they love to do,
you know.
I don't know,
climb the Wall of China,
or whatever it may be.
Go to Africa on a safari
or go to Europe,
see the Eiffel Tower.
I don't know.
To do a song with Snoop Dogg,
bucket list number 1,
there was like nothing
after that, so that was it.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-You're a good dancer,
by the way.
We didn't show that scene,
but there's a whole thing
with a big,
choreographed dance number.
-Yeah, we did a whole
TikTok dance.
I don't know how easy it is.
It took me quite some time
to learn it.
-Could you show me
a couple of moves?
-Yes!
-Then we can learn it at home.
-You are very good
at everything.
I would love to show you, yeah.
-I'm not good at dancing at all,
but I would love to learn.
-Yes, okay.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Basically, okay, so,
feet together.
-Alright, so this is
what I'm going to do.
I go to the club.
[ Laughter ]
I go say hi to the bouncer.
I go, "It's Jimmy.
What's up, man?
Good to see you.
What's going on?
How's the family and the kids?
Alright, good."
I'll go into the club.
So then I go into the club.
-And then you like
bust the move.
-Yeah, I get my drink first.
Get my drank on.
[ Laughter ]
So I get my drink, which is
-You get your chai tea.
-chai tea, of course,
in a giant vase
[ Laughter ]
and then put it off to the side
and I'm ready to hit the floor
and then I do...
-And then you do this.
-Yep.
-Right foot out.
-Okay.
-Close it.
-Uh-huh.
-Left foot out. Close it.
Now, you do a lasso
with the right hand
and then you put your right
foot out and you do it all.
Bam!
[ Laughter ]
-Here's where it gets hard.
Alright.
So I put the lasso out.
-Yeah, and then you swing a hip
while you do it.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Bam, bam!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Bam! Okay.
Yeah.
-Everyone's like,
"Seen that, Jimmy.
You do that move all the time,"
Do I end there?
-No.
-Of course not.
[ Laughter ]
-So you go open, shut.
Open, shut.
Then the lasso.
Bam!
-Bam, yeah, of course.
-Bam!
[ Laughter ]
Then you hop
and you do, you know,
the box step
and you shake your little...
you know what.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I shake my little what?
-Your chest.
-Yes, thank you.
Alright, perfect.
Thank you. Alright, okay.
-So you hop.
-You hop, of course.
-You go, shimmy, shimmy, shimmy.
You do the box step.
And you touch your chest.
[ Laughter ]
Your hair.
-Hair.
-And then you do a quick
bam-bam.
[ Applause ]
-Okay.
-Okay?
-I think I can try this.
You want to give me a beat?
♪♪
-One, two.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Bam! Bam!
Hop.
Shimmy, shimmy, shimmy.
Boobies, hat, bam-bam!
Yes.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-I need a chai tea after that.
Heidi Klum, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
The best.
Check out her and Snoop Dogg's
song "Chai Tea with Heidi."
Heidi and I are playing
a fun musical game
when we come back.
Stick around.
-Yes! Yes!
-Let's try it again. Here we go.
-Okay.
♪♪